it's been a rough couple of days for
Donald Trump the inspiration for the hit
viral video Annoying Orange which I
didn't know a lot of people know there
it is a New York Times investigation
suggested that he may not have paid
taxes since 1995 when he lost almost a
billion dollars with a B it was also
revealed that he made an appearance in a
softcore porn movie right there the New
York Attorney General banned the Trump
foundation from doing any fundraising in
the state and in a late-night tweet
storm he encouraged America to watch a
Miss Universe winners and non-existent
sex tape although I don't know I guess
the phrase check out sex tape could be
an unrelated endorsement for the 2014
Cameron Diaz Jason Segel romp sex tape I
don't know why you was doing that
otherwise some analysts are calling it
the worst week in campaign history worse
even than when William Howard Taft
admitted he had an adult baby fetish you
guys remember that you probably member
that right I'm soiled my guy be burn but
if there's one thing I know about this
jaundice walrus wrapped in cellophane
it's that he never stops topping himself
so comedians what is Trump gonna do this
week to make it even worse Steve Agee
milk his tits on live TV intro
and there's more and try to sell it as
stamina sauce alright yeah points I'll
give you points for that Oh Doug Benson
I heard he's gonna endorse himself
alright good good night
Brendan he's going to reveal that
stop-and-frisk is how he met Milania all
right points